entreprendre au féminin aux antilles
guyane
on en parle dans cette salle moi c'est
important d'être ici a menti lit de
rencontrer d'autres talentueuse autre
femme est de 2,2 me nourrir d'elle des
femmes chefs d'entreprise futurs chefs
d'entreprise ou salariés nous sommes
dans les murs de la sarre à 30% des
effectifs féminins partenaires de
l'opération
il s'agit de faire le point sur les
projets menés par des femmes et surtout
accueillir celles qui ont besoin des
deux pour avancer pour ce faire
l'association forme de goutte est lancé
aujourd'hui même la cohorte des
talentueuses martinique guadeloupe
guyane une quarantaine de projets d'ores
et déjà enregistré beaucoup de femmes
n'ont pas forcément l'audace de pouvoir
pousser plusieurs portes qui mènent vers
la réussite
donc il y en a certaines qui arrive est
forte heureusement et d'autres qui en
vendent un peu plus d'accompagnement
mais aussi d'un carnet d adresses qui
soit
valable et qu'ils puissent justement
leur permettre d'aboutir donc sur des
opportunités d'affaires le principe de
la cohorte c'est de créer un gros donc
de femmes qui ensemble va traverser les
différentes épreuves
dans leurs différents objectifs donc là
dans mon cas précis je suis en phase de
création d'entreprise je veux créer un
cabinet conseil
justement vous remettra au coeur donc
des acteurs la question de l'utilité
sociale
de leur activité et pour limiter les
barrières plusieurs partenaires comme le
groupe caisse des dépôts pour notamment
des aides financières
les femmes chefs d'entreprise sont
souvent dans la restauration
l'agriculture ou les services à la
personne
cet établissement qui a 200 ans
aujourd'hui s'est donné un engagement
depuis quelques années elle adore chaque
année cet objectif à faire accéder les
femmes c'est pas parce qu'elles sont
femmes mais c'est parce qu'elles ont la
compétence parce qu'elle ose est ce que
disent oui je peux dont elles saisissent
l'occasion et la caisse des dépôts l'air
dans toute l'opportunité qu'il faut pour
y arriver
la même opération devrait se dérouler en
guyane jeudi et vendredi prochains